this is going to be the biggest weekend
of our life we can do this let's get a
stripper did anybody see me fall
everybody okay
very around [__] slide layer discs
into the man I'm cute I'm done
[Applause]
sir are you okay mr. I'm looking at one
user Oh God I killed a guy imma call the
police no call we will clean everything
and then we'll call the police let's get
rid of those drugs I want it now my
doing now okay don't tell me what to do
and I will do it huh
I think we should call a lawyer sir my
uncle Jack Carol wasn't even answering
take off this don't touch the body
actually we have already moved team we
gotta get rid of them
oh god no no will want to know we have
to everything all right
yeah great
in America
we three Peters who really know what's
gonna be healthy
I like your banana what I like the
heartbreak behind your head
[Music]
[Applause]
how can you eat right now it is the
number one way people deal with stress
you might want them so yeah I hope you
like
[Music]
you